sand worms are gross looking little
things
ah maybe a little bit cute i almost feel
bad
using them as bait what if
instead of us hunting them they were
able to hunt
us could they make it from
water onto land how much
food would they need to sustain
themselves
and what's so unusual about the way
they'd
eat you this
is what if and here's what would happen
if sand worms were the size of humans
you might find sand worms gross but
they're nothing to be afraid of usually
that is
sand worms live in deep tunnels at the
bottom of the sea
where they prey on lug worms and some
small bivalves
the way they hunt and eat their prey is
pretty terrifying
we're lucky that they don't get larger
than 80 centimeters in length
because if they did well
you'd better see for yourself
the most horrifying thing about a sand
worm is its big
strong jaw sand worms use it to grab on
to poor victims
and this thing that comes out of its
mouth
is part of the digestive tract yeah
they can push it outside of their bodies
gross the good thing is
sand worms are omnivores which means
they eat both
plants and animals that's good because
if they were carnivores they for sure
would want to eat you
but now there might be a slight chance
you'd be safe
naturally sand worms are very
introverted
they don't like to leave their burrows
much giant sand worms would be
good swimmers they'd mostly feed on
algae and
scavenge fish and smaller marine animals
even birds that hunt near shallow waters
might become dinner
and what about people most likely
human-sized sandworms wouldn't eat
humans
that often just try not to make them
angry
but this doesn't mean you'd be
completely safe
sandworms don't have eyes they
couldn't see you when they were
searching for food so they
could accidentally bite you because of
their increased size
sandworms would need to consume more
food
they might leave their home waters of
the antarctic and arctic oceans and
spread further across the planet they
might
even have to evolve and move on to land
so as not to become extinct
the most dangerous time would be during
their mating season when they leave
their burrows
but not because they'd be out and about
they'd have other things on their mind
if you know what i mean
it would be dangerous because larger
predators would travel
to shallow waters to feed on them some
beaches would be off limits and
would have to post warnings about the
sand worms
if they became too much of a problem
humans might decide to reduce the sand
worm population
and didn't i tell you not to make them
angry
hunting sandworms would do precisely
that
they might want to get their revenge
if a sand worm was coming after you it
would happen in the water
unless we're talking about giant evolved
sand worms that would live on land but
more on that in a minute a sand worm
would grab you with its strong jaw
its mouth would be full of sharp teeth
and the bite
would be excruciating a sand worm that's
bigger than you might
try to swallow you it wouldn't chew you
much so
you'd end up in its reeking slippery
crop right away
that's where worms temporarily store
their food
you might still be conscious and in a
lot of pain
in the worms gizzard you'd get ground up
together with ingested sand
if you were to escape you'd better do
that now while you still might be able
to cut your way out with a sharp object
if not you'd move through its intestine
where all
your nutrients would be absorbed
whatever was left of you would be
pooped out let's just hope that
sandworms
wouldn't evolve into spice producing 750
meter long
thick desert living giants you'd stand
no chance against those well
maybe if you yourself grew to be five
meters tall
but that's a story for another
what if